au d'écriture beaucoup parler vous
écrivez ceci une écriture graphique le
mot pour le mot le mot véhiculant l'idée
non pas l'idée véhiculant le mot
primordial j'écrivais des chansons parce
que simplement des mots vous amène à des
idées et non pas les al'inverse sous
aucun prétexte
je ne veux 20 de flex malheureux ou 1.41
qui troue le cul du chantre du brut du
vent et qu'est ce que vous voyez que ce
sont des mots qui lui n'est donc pas les
lui l'idée qu'il lâche et je suis
persuadé que la que les chanteurs qui
sont à ma gauche là ne sont pas d'accord
là mais enfin bon mais chacun à sa
manière des conseils dans l'apparence et
les mauvais jours vous êtes d'accord
des applis qui veulent lire aussi ça qui
doit énerver déjà mais est ce qu'il fait
c'est vrai que j'aurais jamais moi je
sais que j'aurai jamais chanté s'il ya
ce but a existé jamais fait chaud vers
l'est l'a déjà dit de la musique avant
toute chose il déroule un verrou il
était à sa table là bas l'autre quart
gainsbourg non mais c'est idiot cents
contre vous il ya un petit contentieux
la wii non mais je connais pas je n'y
des options chine l'avs il alexandra
neri mon âge
initialement m cependant la suite
ensuite quand quand on compose la
guitare
e
et encore quand on a fait des années
depuis un barça la guitare
sa gueule c'est du riz bob dylan à
compostelle compenser la guitare grâce à
la guitare ou dit gosper la guitare
mieux maintenant bien après avoir tenté
cris il faut lire et j'engage pierre
perret à nous chanter sa chanson lire